they were meant to be avenging the
killing of their top commander but
Iran's all-powerful Revolutionary Guard
also shot down a civilian plane now a
confession hard to say well i confirmed
what had happened I really wished I
could die myself I said I wished I could
die it's not when there's such an event
for a lifetime we've made ourselves
ready to die for the people today we're
trading our reputation with Almighty God
he explained why Iranian forces fired
the missile seen here as a flash of
light at the Ukrainian aircraft they
mistakenly thought it was an incoming
cruise missile launched by US forces
hours after Iran struck American targets
across the border in Iraq
it's an extraordinary admission of
failure this is the cost of the miss
chief information and actions of that
night we were ready for a full-scale
conflict for Ukraine there are questions
too about its decisions
why did authoritative fly from Tehran at
a time of such intense hostilities if
the American side had said to us that we
should abandon our flight and maybe we
should have listened to them but it was
just a normal situation unfortunately
what happened you can't turn back the
clock we agree that some of the fault
may be on us but I say again you can't
predict everything that happens in life
otherwise you'd just freeze and do
nothing
Ukrainians will be relieved that Iran
has come clean for the past five and a
half years they've had to deal with
denials from Russia of involvement with
the downing of another passenger jet
linked to this country malaysia airlines
mh17 was brought down in eastern ukraine
by a surface-to-air missile allegedly
fired by russia-backed rebels at Kiev
Airport bosses of the Ukrainian airline
used maps to show other civilian flights
were taking off around the same time as
theirs at the moment
of the flight act from Bristol Airport
we had no information on the possible
threats up till the moment of our flight
taking off from Teheran we had no
information on any possible threats many
questions still for Iran as it deals
with the fallout some - perhaps for
president Donald Trump his order to kill
Major General Qasem Soleimani prompted
the Iranians to strike that night and
put their air defenses on alert but in a
bizarre twist of fate the plane disaster
may deal a bigger blow to Tehran and
it's Revolutionary Guard than any
assassination Deborah Haynes Sky News
give